but first joining us now he guided the
whole process
as promised senate judiciary committee
chairman uh lindsey graham is with us
well i did notice a little bit of a
tempeh tantrum and there are a lot of
threats going on about packing the court
and
ending the legislative filibuster and
amnesty and a lot of power grabs
not easy well the internet's melting
down i mean there is an absolute desire
to take me out
lindsey graham.com i need your help now
more than ever
but to the american people you're the
biggest winner tonight
you have a constitutional conservative
woman who understands the difference
between my job
and being a judge she's one of the most
highly
educated people ever to go on the court
she's not from harvard she's not from
yale
she is a normal person she's going to do
an awesome job thank you president trump
but the big winner tonight is
conservative women to all those
conservative women
who go through hell for being
conservative who get beat up by the
mainstream media
for embracing your faith being pro-life
being traditional in your family
structure
you're a winner tonight there's a seat
at the table for you this is not a glass
ceiling being broken this is a concrete
barrier being broken
amy barrett represents every aspiration
of a young conservative woman
she's going to do awesome i cannot wait
for her to
be on the supreme court tomorrow in many
ways i suspect i've been watching this
whole process and we all saw what
happened with
with now justice kavanaugh that the
democrats had
not been so close to a little an
election would have smeared slandered
besmirched
and they would have they would do what
they did to kavanagh or would have done
and and justice thomas who will
administer the oath tonight and
and what they did to robert bork if they
could they would have
but instead i i want to get your take
on this we're going to pack the courts
everything's on the table
and the legislative filibuster d.c
puerto rico
statehood full-on amnesty i assume
something of value they would appreciate
votes and future elections that to me
now talk speaks of one party rule
and they'll do it your thoughts
they're going to do it now the only
reason they won't do it is if the
american people stop them
we must maintain control of the united
states senate you got
joanie ernst on the ballot from iowa
you've got martha mcsally two great
conservative women
women you got susan collins who's been
just
terrific senator for maine helped judge
kavanaugh helped us with the tax cuts
so help all of us we cannot turn over
the entire government
to this radical left schumer's speech
tonight was disgusting
uh he's the guy that started the
filibuster with bush 43
he's the guy along with senator kennedy
who declared war on all things
conservative it's a leto it's kavanaugh
it's thomas it's fork it's not the
process they tried to destroy judge
cavanaugh's life
amy barrett is probably a beneficiary
from the kavanaugh hearings it blew up
in their face
the american people hated what they did
to kavanaugh so i think they were more
respectful to judge barrett
but let me just say this the internet is
on fire tonight foul
they are raising money like crazy to
take back the senate and beat president
trump
help me help everybody i just named
lindseygram.com these people want it men
my opponents raised 109 million dollars
the most in the united states
history of the united states senate
let's all fight back together but let's
celebrate tonight
president trump you put three great
conservative justices on the court is so
pivotal in the first term conservatives
need to understand what
what court packing would mean what dc
puerto rico statehood would mean
oh my god what what all of these
paragraphs by the way we've been given
the one minute the white house swearing
in of amy coney
barrett the swearing-in will be done by
justice clarence thomas
um by the way if you've never read his
book my grandfather's son is a great
book i still tell everybody all the time
yeah but all of this higher taxes
amnesty when i say this is the tipping
point of all tipping point elections
you're right it's your race it's tillis
it's joni ernst it's martha mcsally it's
corey gardner
it's purdue it is mitch mcconnell
uh you know all of us even susan
collison disagreed with on this vote
it is all in the balance because they
will do this
what would that mean to the country
okay number one they're going to take
the number nine and expand it to
probably 13
to wipe out the conservative majority
they'll pack it with liberals
that means the court loses its
independence they'll do away with the
legislative filibuster
they're going to do away with electoral
college which means new york and
california pick the president in
perpetuity
iowa south carolina and arizona won't
count anymore
they're going to have open borders and
free health care for illegal immigrants
all of them raise their hand they will
turn this country from a free enterprise
nation to a socialist nation
from a law and order nation to chaos
they will they will reward the most
radical agenda in the history of the
country that's trying to take us
all out now we got a chance here to make
history
can you imagine four more years music
means uh the first lady
is just uh the big guy the big guy
they're playing uh that music that means
the president is entering let's
go live to the swearing-in ceremony